albanien eine geheime stellung der
alliierten aus dem zweiten weltkrieg
das war nicht bloß ein partisan camp
sondern auch ein flucht versteckt
eine psychiatrische anstalt in den usa
berüchtigt für ihre grausamen methoden
die chirurgen machten experimente am
gehirn manche teile beschädigten sie
absichtlich
und die höhle einer satanischen
gemeinschaft zu deren mitgliedern ein
amerikanischer gründungsvater zählt
ein seltsamer ein unheimlicher ort mit
einer unglaublichen geschichte von
glamour prominenz und ausschweifungen
zerfallende bauten ruinen aus
vergangener zeit einst mühsam erschaffen
heute nur noch schatten ihrer selbst
zeit ihre geheimnisse zu lüften
[Musik]
auf einer halbinsel im südosten europas
liegt das land der adler albanien
verborgen in den hügeln sind die
überreste einer dramatischen geschichte
eine sehr bergige region wunderschön
aber auch ein bisschen trostlos
geht eine landschaft von rauer schönheit
und große einsamkeit vielleicht eines
der abgelegensten länder europas
ein geheimnisvoller ort den größten teil
des letzten jahrhunderts praktisch
unzugänglich bis heute hat er etwas
mysteriöses
da gibt es immer noch viel zu entdecken
geheimnisse aus vielen jahrzehnten
der zweite weltkrieg hat auch in dieser
verlassenen region seine spuren
hinterlassen
auf einem hügel mit blick auf die bucht
von flora steht ein relikt aus diesen
dunklen zeiten
aus diesem dorf standen 45 männer die in
albanien als märtyrer gelten helden des
zweiten weltkriegs hier hat sich eine
phänomenale geschichte abgespielt
ein paar kilometer weiter liegt eine
geheimnis von der höhle sie spielt die
hauptrolle in dieser geschichte
ein maschinengewehr stativ das ist der
beweis
hier versteckten sich die partisanen es
war ihre basis
was haben britische und amerikanische
geheimagenten in dieser abgelegenen
region verloren
eine klassische geschichte aus dem
zweiten weltkrieg mit spionen partisanen
schmugglern helden schurken einfach
allem
diese unscheinbare siedlung spielt
während des zweiten weltkriegs eine
schlüsselrolle bei geheimen operationen
britische und amerikanische us agenten
von hier aus führen sie einen
guerillakrieg
ex geheimagent print jannis will die
geschichte auf den grund gehen
ich war bei den us boys im irak das sind
absolute spezialisten in sachen
guerillakrieg
weil ich herausfinden warum die vorgänge
der modernen spezialeinheiten dieses
zerstörte dorf als operationsbasis
auswirken
die geheimdienste haben damals
strategien entwickelt die heute noch
aktuell sind
gegründet werden die beiden
organisationen während des zweiten
weltkriegs sie koordinieren
spionageaktivitäten hinter den
feindlichen linien um auf dem unwegsamen
gelände voran zu kommen braucht ja nur
ließ ein starkes auto
als ich hier hoch vor stellte ich mir
vor ich musste diese stellung einnehmen
eine ziemliche schnapsidee denn die
stellung ist extrem gut befestigt
von unten kann man kaum etwas erkennen
ich selbst aber völlig ungeschützt hier
oben ist man dagegen sicher vor beschuss
und hat fast einen rundumblick
wie eine festung dass die scharfschützen
stellung
selbst mit kleineren
artilleriegeschützen war man hier sicher
von jo schlautmann über das ganze tal
ideal geeignet um es mit einer
streitmacht aufzunehmen die von dort
anrückt
[Musik]
aus der nähe betrachtet sind überall
kampfspuren zu erkennen
ganz klar hier wurde geschossen da sind
einschusslöcher aus mörsern wieder sehen
aus wie von normalen kugeln
manche sehen aus wie artillerie feuer
die sind großflächige gestreut
die wirklich wichtige frage für mich
lautet wer tier angegriffen und wo
kommen sie her denn hinter diesen beiden
starken festungen lauert eine todesfalle
für jeden der versucht ins dorf zu
gelangen
januar trifft sich mit
dessen familie lebt sie hier bevor die
kämpfe losging
das sind die namen meines urgroßvaters
und ur urgroßvaters
[Musik]
sie hatten drei zimmer 1 hier ein star
und das dritte hier das ist das haus
meiner vorfahren hier lebten mein
großvater mein urgroßvater und mein
ururgroßvater wie sie sehen ist es nur
noch eine ruine
alles wegen des zweiten weltkriegs
[Musik]
der ort heißt rogers und wurde im
sechsten jahrhundert vor christus
gegründet
einst leben ihr hunderte familien gegen
fremde invasoren setzen sie sich immer
wieder erfolgreich zur wehr
dies ist ein ort an dem kriegerische
konflikte an der tagesordnung waren die
menschen hatten kaum kontakt zur
außenwelt
von fremden wollten sie sich nicht sagen
lassen
jahrhundertelang während die
dorfbewohner türkische angriffe ab
1847 schlagen sie die armee des
osmanischen reichs in die flucht
sind es die türken die sich später für
diese ungeheuerlichkeit rächen um den
dingen auf den grund zu gehen fährt
klingt ja nu ließ in die bucht von flora
dort hat der krieg zahlreiche spuren
hinterlassen
ich will beide seiten verstehen
die partisanen thrashers die oben in den
bergen und hier in der bucht aktiv an
und ich will dieses frack untersuchen
damit ich die offizielle seite besser
verstehen
[Musik]
wenn man durch das trübe wasser zu
einzelnen teilen des schiffes schwimmt
kann man sich fast vorstellen was ihr
früher los war
wahnsinn
so umwerfend
unglaublich man sieht die löcher im
schiff die umrisse des motors
alles glasklar
einfach fantastisch
das beste schiffswrack dass ich hier
untersucht habe
die untersuchung bringt überraschungen
ans licht und wirft neue fragen auf
welcher hochrangige passagier war hier
an bord und war das schiff am angriff
auf truckers beteiligt
der ex geheimagent klingt ja nu ließ
untersuchter schiffs war gründlich denn
es erzählt viel über die geheime
geschichte der region
das schiff viel einem verheerenden
angriff zum opfer es war aber kein
kriegsschiff es hatte weder kanonen noch
bordgeschütze was ist da geschehen
das schiff stammt aus einer zeit vor
beginn des zweiten weltkriegs damals
startet der italienische diktator benito
mussolini einen überraschungsangriff auf
wichtige albanische hafenanlagen
darunter flora dass bei truckers liegt
sie wollte sein imperium vergrößern und
albanien war leichte beute
es lag gleich gegenüber auf der anderen
seite der adria
als mussolinis truppen von albanien aus
die grenze nach griechenland
überschreiten greift großbritannien ein
braves bomber attackieren italienische
schiffe in der region eins davon ist die
po im märz 1941 wird sie vom britischen
torpedos versenkt
das schiff war unbeleuchtet die
britischen piloten hielten es für ein
legitimes militärisches ziel sie hatten
ja keine ahnung womit sie es zu tun
hatten und wer an bord war
tatsächlich ist die po ein
lazarettschiff sie evakuiert
italienische soldaten von der albanisch
griechischen front
zufällig war eine der krankenschwestern
an bord mussolinis tochter
yano überlebt den angriff
mussolini strategie aber kommt italien
bald teuer zu stehen
italien verliert an allen fronten
ausrüstung führung moral alles geht den
bach runter es wird immer schwieriger
schlüsselregionen unter kontrolle zu
halten und zu denen zählt definitiv die
albanische küste
der albanische widerstand wittert seine
chance treasures wird stützpunkt und
materiallager für die partisanen die
jetzt ihrerseits die italiener angreifen
die partisanen wollen kämpfen und haben
erfolg denn das tera ist ideal geeignet
für ihre art der kriegsführung
klingt ja nur ließ ist zurück in
truckers er will wissen warum der ort
eine so zentrale rolle spielte
ich erkunde das dorf unter logistischen
gesichtspunkten
die praktischen vorteile werden sofort
offensichtlich
starke mauern raue landschaft solide
bauten aber mich interessiert vor allem
die logistik
die entscheidung über sieg oder
niederlage
spezialeinheiten kehren die logistische
kette
normalerweise gilt für armin je größer
die armee und die logistik desto besser
kleine einheiten mit wenigen soldaten
finden die schwachpunkte der
logistikkette und zerstören sie
ist wasser ein wichtiger faktor
das hier ist eine natürliche quelle
wasserversorgung für das ganze jahr
angreifer die von unten kommen müssen
ihr wasser auf schleppen
das ist ja cool
erinnert mich an griechische dörfer in
denen ich schon war sie waren verwinkelt
und labyrinthisch angelegt um piraten
abzuschrecken
wer zu fuß rein kam musste durch
korridor und engpässe so genannte
trichter des todes
dank dieser vorteile machen die
partisanen der italienischen armee das
leben zur hölle
immer wieder werden die truppen opfer
von blitz angriffen schließlich reicht
es dem italienischen oberbefehlshaber
franco clementi mit einer kompletten
division will er die kontrolle über
truckers und die vier nachbardörfer
zurückgewinnen
am neujahrstag 1943 fand eine große
schlacht statt 2000 gut ausgerüstete
italiener werden von den albanischen
partisanen zurückgeschlagen der kampf
david gegen goliath endet mit dem sieg
der albaner
clementi erhöht die truppenstärke auf
5000 mann auf jeden albaner kommen drei
italiener trotzdem erleidet er eine
demütigende niederlage und kommt selbst
ums leben
es dauert nicht lange bis mussolini
streitkräfte zurückkehren um sich zu
rächen
an den zivilisten
die italiener griffen an es heißt sie
hätten von dem berg oberhalb des dorfes
uhrig um das feuer mit mörsern eröffnet
sie fackelten das dorf aber und
vertrieben die bewohner
doch die italienische armee trifft auf
größer werden den widerstand
zur unterstützung der partisanen
schicken die alliierten kleine
spezialeinheiten
gemeinsam kämpfen sie gegen mussolini
und gegen die nazis die ebenfalls in
albanien einmarschieren
die truppe um den britischen soldaten
jerry viel schlägt intra dass ihr lager
auf
[Musik]
ein britischer geheimagent vom
sogenannten s ii mit einer kleinen
einheit kammer nach tages um die
partisanen so gut es ging zu
unterstützen er gab informationen an die
briten weiter und versuchte den nazis
möglichst großen schaden zuzufügen ohne
dabei britische truppen zu involvieren
nur er selbst und sein kleines team
waren betroffen
als hauptaufgabe waffen aus italien
einschmuggeln dort sind die alliierten
inzwischen gelandet
nach dem amerikaner und briten 1943 den
süden italiens besetzt hatten war es von
bari aus nur noch ein katzensprung über
die adria bis nach albanien da war es
relativ leicht die partisanen vom meer
aus mit material und kleineren einheiten
zu unterstützen
[Musik]
klingt ja nu ließ vermutet dass die
britischen sondereinheiten truckers
plötzlich verließen hinweise darauf
findet er an einem besonderen ort
erst heute noch schwer zu finden auf
keiner karte eingezeichnet um selbst die
meisten einheimischen wissen nicht dass
es ihn gibt
damit habe ich nicht gerechnet
das hier ist eine maschinengewehr hatte
rum hier steht marc vier 1942
darauf kann man ein schweres
maschinengewehr setzen
wir den hügel hoch kam musste mit
trommelfeuer rechnen das ding ist
verdammt schwer
die hülle kann nicht weit sein
gleich da
das ist kein normaler felsvorsprung da
geht es tief rein
das muss es sein
da ist ein maschinengewehr stativ das
ist der beweis
hier versteckten sich die partisanen
es war ihre basis
was hat die höhle mit einer
bemerkenswerten amerikanischen
fluchtgeschichte zu tun
das ist ein großartiges versteck aber
auch eine schreckliche todes verlernt
ein paar handgranaten hier rein und du
wirst von stalaktiten durchbohrt
das muss ihnen sorge bereitet haben da
hätte schon einen bombentreffer genügt
stellen sie sich vor eine 500 pfund
bombe schlägt da oben ein
field und sein team ziehen um von
trottas in dieser höhle mit meerblick
ein perfekt getarntes versteck im wald
einer verborgenen bucht über die waffen
und vorräten nach albanien geschmuggelt
werden
monate lang ernähren sich field und
seine männer nur von esel fleisch und
reden wasser
was für ein seltsames leben du wohnst in
dieser höhle ist jeden tag raus zum
kämpfen oder um vorräte zu holen
sabotiert den feind und kommt abends
zurück und ist esel braten
[Musik]
nachdem die nazis field und seine männer
aus thrashers vertrieben haben finden
sie unterschlupf in dieser höhle
schon bald wird sich zeigen dass sie
mehr ist als nur ein geheimnis versteckt
einem us flugzeug mit 13
krankenschwestern an bord ging der
treibstoff aus zudem war schlechte sicht
es musste auf einem feld mitten in
albanien notlanden und das im winter
in einem von nazis besetzten gebiet ohne
nahrung oder ausrüstung die partisanen
schmuggeln die gestrandeten
krankenschwestern quer über die
schneebedeckten berge bis zur küste sie
mussten deutschen spähtrupps aus dem weg
gehen einmal wurden sie fast erwischt
als die deutschen ein dorf eroberten
dabei wurden sie getrennt aber alle
überlebten und setzten ihren weg haut
sie erreichen mit hilfe der britischen
agenten schließlich die geheime höhle
grant jan hollis selbst sanitäter glaubt
ein beweisstück von damals gefunden zu
haben
das ist verbandszeug aus dem zweiten
weltkrieg
sieht nicht viel anders aus als heute
ist aber 76 jahre alt
man kann immer noch die baumwoll
nachsehen ziemlich cool
wie gelingt den frauen eine der
bemerkenswertesten fluchten des zweiten
weltkriegs
mit hilfe der partisanen erreichen die
13 amerikanischen krankenschwestern die
küste unentdeckt von den deutschen
besatzern von hier aus führen alliierte
agenten sie zu einer geheimen bucht dort
wartet ein amerikanisches boot um sie
nach italien zu bringen
nach hunderten kilometern fußmarsch
durch unwegsames gelände mitten im
winter trafen die krankenschwestern also
hier auf die eso agenten
hätten bereits den transport organisiert
die frauen kamen also genau wie ich
durch diese schlucht und das erste was
sie sahen diese schmuggler bucht von
hier ging es für sie nach hause
am ende hatten sie über 1000 kilometer
zu fuß zurückgelegt
es ist eine der großen über
lebensgeschichten des zweiten weltkriegs
die krankenschwestern sind auf dem
heimweg die dorfbewohner und partisanen
bleiben in ihrer heimat einem
kriegsgebiet für sie gibt es keine
flucht
januars will wissen was nach fields
abreise aus ihnen wurde
was taten die nazis gegen den widerstand
der von diesem dorf ausging
sie brannten alles nieder sie zerstörten
alles sie sehen ja die ruinen die leute
mussten das dorf verlassen und woanders
neu anfangen hier gab es nur noch
brandmauern und ruinen
die deutschen beschlossen das dorf zu
vernichten und die britischen und
amerikanischen agenten mussten von den
umliegenden bergen aus zu sehen
die menschen mit denen sie so lange
erfolgreich kooperiert hatten verloren
auf einen schlag alles
die nazis brennen das dorf nieder ein
grund mehr für die einheimischen den
kampf aufzunehmen
mein ältester onkel schloss sich der
fünften partie sahen brigade an
erkämpfte sogar in jugoslawien gegen die
deutschen
[Musik]
diese geschichte erinnert daran was für
ein tödliches chaos der zweite weltkrieg
war
viele menschen gingen große risiken ein
wurden verwundet oder sterben
dürfen wir diesen standen die menschen
tagtäglich vor der frage widerstand zu
leisten oder nicht
solche entscheidungen konnten zur
hinrichtung ganze familien führen
zusammen mit den alliierten soldaten
kämpften sie für heimatland dabei
riskierten sie das leben ihrer familien
ihr eigenes leben das leben ihre
nachbarn
[Musik]
heute erinnert ein denkmal an den
tapferen widerstand der partisanen gegen
die mächte des faschismus
[Musik]
am ufer des forever im herzen von west
virginia usa steht ein gebäudekomplex
mit einer unglaublichen geschichte
wirklich imposanter bau erinnert an die
kolonialzeit und scheint zivilen zwecken
gedient zu haben
dann sind da noch jede menge andere
gebäude wie auf einem uni-campus das
muss für seine zeit ein riesenprojekt
gewesen sein
das innere wirkt zunächst irritierend
was spielte sich hier ab
der kontrast aus kinderspielzeug und
medizinischen instrumenten ist irgendwie
unheimlich
da herrscht totales chaos ein
verlassenes gebäude eben die farbe
blättert von den wänden türen und
fenster sind vergittert ein
abschreckender ort
offensichtlich sollten die menschen hier
nicht rauskommen aber häftlinge waren
sie nicht
dieser ort sollte einem guten zweck
dienen er sollte ein zufluchtsort für
ausgestoßen und vertriebene seien
es begann als gut gemeintes experiment
wurde aber schnell zu einer horror show
des missbrauchs
wie konnte der traum zum albtraum werden
und wer wurde hier gefangen gehalten
die bauarbeiten beginnen mitte des
neunzehnten jahrhunderts wenige jahre
später geschehen hier schreckliche dinge
dinge die in diesen räumen aber auch in
der umliegenden gemeinde tiefe spuren
hinterlassen ein ort für psychisch
kranke in einer zeit in der vermeintlich
geisteskranke anders betrachtet werden
als heute wer symptome zeigt könnte von
dämonen besessen sein
[Musik]
anfang des neunzehnten jahrhunderts war
die behandlung einer psychischen
erkrankung fast schlimmer als ein
todesurteil
kranke familienangehörige wurden daher
oft versteckt denn sonst wurden sie
abtransportiert und eingesperrt
psychische krankheiten waren damals noch
nicht richtig erforscht man vermutete
etwas übersinnliches dahinter das
englische wort lunatic verrückter deutet
auf den mond hin
ein fortschrittlicher mediziner aber
geht neue wege sein name dr thomas koep
breit
kirk breit war einer der seltenen
reformer er glaubte an eine neue methode
der schlüssel war eine möglichst normale
gesunde umgebung
dieser ort sollte sein meisterstück
werden
[Musik]
das
trendige zeilen
mitte des 19 jahrhunderts änderten sich
allmählich die vorstellungen über
psychische erkrankungen die klinik
sollte ein ort für fortschrittliche und
humane behandlungsmethoden seien
wollte sich von üblichen methoden der
fesselung psychisch kranker in
gefängnissen lösen
stattdessen ließ er ein prächtiges
hauptgebäude errichten es war so
konzipiert dass viel licht und luft
herein kommen konnten anders als in
dunklen und feuchten zählen
ursprünglich sollen hier 250 patienten
untergebracht werden sie haben die
freiheit durch die langen hellen
korridore zu wandeln oder den gepflegten
garten zu genießen
aber schon bald wird nicht mehr viel
übrig sein vom körper als großer
humanistischer vision
was das verständnis von psychischen
erkrankungen betraf steckte die
wissenschaft noch in den kinderschuhen
da wurden sogar patienten mit epilepsie
fehlenden gliedmaßen oder asthma
eingeliefert
frauen die sich unkonventionell
verhielten wurden für verrückt erklärt
und weggesperrt
wer nicht den gesellschaftlichen
erwartungen entsprach konnte als nerven
krank eingestuft werden was seine
behandlung erforderlich machte
auf dem höhepunkt ist die klinik mit
2.600 patienten vollgestopft zehnmal
mehr als ursprünglich geplant je mehr
die zahlen in die höhe schnellen desto
fragwürdiger werden die
behandlungsmethoden wie rebecca gleeson
weiß die orte für das gebäude
verantwortlich ist
es waren so viele patienten hier das
eine vernünftige behandlung unmöglich
war sie wurden hier praktisch
eingelagert
viele mussten auf dem boden schlafen mit
der ursprünglich angestrebten
therapeutischen atmosphäre hatte das
nichts zu tun
und es kommt noch schlimmer
bald werden psychisch kranke häftlinge
aus umliegenden gefängnissen in der
klinik untergebracht
wir dürfen nicht vergessen es gab
patienten mit verschiedenen psychischen
behinderungen menschen mit schweren
depressionen bipolare störungen
schizophrenie
viele unterschiedliche mentalen
störungen
und dann kam noch kriminelle dazu
es muss ein furchtbarer ort gewesen sein
es gab übergriffe und sogar morde da
muss ständig eine atmosphäre der angst
geherrscht haben
gewalt und schreckliche zustände sind
nur die spitze des eisbergs
das gehirn und psychische störungen
waren noch nicht sehr erforscht die
behandlungsmethoden waren oft
willkürlich und grausam in den 1950 er
jahren wurde es noch schlimmer als das
zentrum zur heimat des west virginia
lobotomie projekts wurde
der mann dahinter sdr wollte freeman ein
überzeugter verfechter der lobotomie
eine eispickel lobotomie wurde so ein
metall spies in die augenhöhle geschoben
einschlag um den schädel zu brechen
ein zweiter um an den pre von tal appen
zu gelangen
es ging hin und her wie der
scheibenwischer am auto
man glaubte patienten die unter
zwanghaftem verhalten litten hätten
feste schaltkreise im gehirn die ärzte
bewegten das metall so lange hin und her
bis die verbindungen gekappt waren
aus heutiger sicht eine unvorstellbare
barbarische methode aber damals begibt
sich selbst die schwester eines us
präsidenten bei freeman in behandlung
den rest ihres lebens mehr als 50 jahre
verbrachte sie in eine heilanstalt sie
murmelte nur noch unverständliches zeug
ohne den eingriff wäre ihr die
einweisung in eine anstalt womöglich
erspart geblieben
die meisten patienten waren danach nur
noch ein schatten ihrer selbst saßen nur
noch passiv herum sie waren zwar nicht
mehr aggressiv besaßen aber auch keinen
gesunden verstand mehr
dass ein chirurg geschweige denn ein
gehirn chirurg denken konnte es sei eine
gute idee einen metall spies ins auge
zusammen und damit im gehirn
herumzuwühlen ist wirklich unglaublich
was wird aus dem transall agony lunatic
asylum und seinen patienten
die meisten verlassen den ort nicht
lebendig der einzige bereich in dem er
platz geschaffen wird ist der friedhof
das ist unser leichenschauhaus tausende
sind während der letzten 130 jahre hier
gestorben
in so einem kühlfach lagen normalerweise
zwei leichen
es gab zeiten da waren die wände voll
mit solchen kühlfächer
1994 werden die tore der anstalt für
immer geschlossen
das leiden ist endlich vorbei
man kann sich ungefähr vorstellen wie
entsetzt drk breit gewesen wäre hätte er
gewusst dass seine visionäre anstalt
sich in so eine hölle verwandeln würde
in der sich der zustand der patientin
nicht nur nicht verbessert sondern
oftmals verschlechterte
[Musik]
heute ist das gebäude verlassen ein
verstören das mahnmal für ein gut
gemeintes projekt das auf schreckliche
weise gescheitert ist ein unheimlicher
ort manche der schrecken verschwinden
nie sie überdauern in der einen oder
anderen form
[Musik]
50 kilometer westlich von bombay eine
typisch englische landschaft zwischen
den sanft geschwungenen hügeln liegt die
öffnung zu einer unterirdischen welt
[Musik]
da ist diese kritische worte
dahinter geht es immer weiter runter und
du kommst in diese düsteren höhlen
da sind versteckte dunkle kammern mit
schweren metalltüren fast wie z
ein seltsamer ein unheimlicher ort mit
einer unglaublichen geschichte voller
glamour prominenz und vor allem
ausschweifungen
was macht diese höhlen berühmt
berüchtigt und was haben amerikas
gründerväter damit zu tun
mitte des achtzehnten jahrhunderts
entstehen die ersten visa unterirdischen
gänge
ihre geschichte strotzt nur so vor
heidnischen ritualen schwarzer magie und
skandalösen lastern
jacko hat sich mit der historie
beschäftigt
das höhlensystem erstreckt sich über 400
meter das besondere daran ist dass
nichts davon auf natürliche weise
entstanden ist alles ist zu 100 prozent
von menschen gemacht vor 250 jahren eine
unglaubliche ingenieursleistung
aus den stollen stammt die kreide mit
der eine wichtige verbindungsstraße nach
london gebaut wurde
es ist schockierend was aus diesen
höhlen wurde es klingt wie der stoff aus
einer sage oder legende aber das hier
ist wirklich passiert
jetzt kommen wir ins herz erhöhen hier
wird die eigentlich banale geschichte
plötzlich mag aber es
sind die sogenannten hellfire caves
heimat eines prominenten britischen
geheimbundes
dem hellfire klappt gehörten einige der
berühmtesten und angesehensten männer
ihrer zeit an der begründer war
franziska
schmidt war ein wohlhabender sprössling
des landadels wie die meisten mitglieder
seiner klasse verbrachte er die letzten
jahre seiner ausbildung an europäischen
höfen er beschäftigte sich mit den
schönen künsten und allem was der
kontinent sonst noch zu bieten hatte
[Musik]
seine wahre bestimmung fand er in
italien wo er sich leidenschaftlich ins
studium der verbotenen künste stürzte
besonders der mysterien von neuses einem
berühmten griechischen initiation school
inspiriert von den neuen eindrücken
gründet der schritt nach seiner rückkehr
auf dem familiensitz den exklusiven
hellfire klappt
die gerüchteküche brodelte es hieß dass
in den höhlen schwarze magie und
satanische rituale praktiziert wurden
die mitglieder beteten nicht nur den
teufel an sie wussten auch wie man
feierte
premier brown aus london nahmen im
nonnenkostüm an den festen teil junge
mädchen aus der nachbarschaft wurden
angeblich bezahlt um sich auf altare
zulegen und sich wein aus dem bauchnabel
schlürfen zu lassen
damals gab es hier vorhänge und betten
in den kammern
an den wänden sehen sie noch die kerben
mit denen die männer buch führten über
ihre sexuellen aktivitäten mit den
prostituierten
einige der berühmtesten zeitgenossen
beteiligen sich an dem lüsternen treiben
darunter auch ein einflussreicher
amerikaner
[Musik]
der hellfire klappt hat da einige
berühmte mitglieder aber der berühmteste
war der maler william
hat sich auch eher an den wänden
verewigt
aber eine der finsteren gestalten dies
durchaus mit dashboard aufnehmen konnte
kam aus den usa
war einer der gründerväter der
vereinigten staaten er war mit den
esch-fonds befreundet und kamen
regelmäßig zu besuch dann haben eher an
den skandalträchtigen
unterirdischen party style
liebte den freizügigen spaß denn der
club veranstaltete in briefen an seine
freundin philadelphia hat er dashboard
auf der welt
einmal schrieb der schweizer nie dritte
sowohl über als auch unter der erde zu
tage
der schmutz und co haben einiges zu
verlieren sie tun alles um ihr hoch
loses treiben geheim zu halten um ihren
ruf zu schützen nahmen die mitglieder
sogar andere identitäten an
der hofer extrem wichtig ein falsches
wort und man war ruiniert
außerdem waren teufels anbetung und der
besitz von büchern über schwarze magie
und ähnliches verboten
viel von dem was damals passierte ist
unbekannt unterlagen wurden verbrannt
oder vernichtet um den skandal zu
vertuschen
obwohl die mitglieder sich zu
verschwiegenheit verpflichtet haben
kommt früher oder später etwas heraus
irgendwie erfuhr die öffentlichkeit von
den sexuellen ausschweifungen
der legende nach war es ein ehemaliges
mitglied das den klub los stellte
der öffentliche aufschrei sorgte dafür
dass der klub 1766 schließen musste
es heißt der schmuck habe nach der
schließung ein anständiges leben geführt
er stirbt
auch dieser unglaubliche feuerstein baus
der schöpfung
das mausoleum seiner familie wie alles
hier hat doch diese seine dunkle seite
der schmutz und seine vier frauen liegen
hier begraben
genau wie ein weiteres skandalumwobenen
mitglied des hellfire klappt
früher war in der mitte des mausoleums
eine urne mit dem herz von
whitehead war ein ehemaliger dichter und
mitglied des hellfire
klapproth hier fast 100 jahre friedlich
bis zum beginn der viktorianischen ära
die viktorianer waren seltsam sie
liebten den tod hatte machten sie das
hier zu einer touristenattraktion
es heißt vor etwa 100 jahren hätten
australische besucher das herz gestohlen
seitdem spukt whitehead in den höhlen
und hügeln und sucht nach der stelle an
der sein herz begraben liegt
heute sind die helfer aktivste
öffentlichkeit zugänglich wer so richtig
auf den spuren des alten der schrott
wandeln möchte kann sie sogar für partys
buchen
mit ihrem ausschweifenden geschichte
haben die höhlen ein bleibendes
vermächtnis hinterlassen heute gehören
sie zu den gruseligsten orten in ganz
england
[Musik]
heute sind viele der bauten vergessen
und verlassen manche ruinen erinnern an
dunkle zeiten andere waren einst
leuchtende beispiele für technologischen
fortschritt und hoffnung stille zeugen
von erfindungsreichtum
unternehmungsgeist und tatendrang
[Musik]